[Music]
foreign
is the biggest dragon scene in live
action in the universe of House of the
dragon and Game of Thrones but here we
will showcase seven movie dragons bigger
than her firstly how big is vegar to
start with the officially still size of
150 meters is way off course than the
dragon that was seen in the series just
check out this estimate of ours this
gigantic yellowish dragon scene in House
of the Dragon was actually between 250
to 300 feet long or between 76 to 90
meters so what are the ones that are
actually bigger and more massive let's
get to it
well the first one here is the Red Death
which isn't just 122 meters or 400 feet
long but also massive in body size and
bulk seen in the very first How to Train
Your Dragon movie The Red Death was the
main antagonist that drove the divide
and hatred between dragons and humans
its head is heavily armed with a nasal
horn coral shaped Frills and Jaws that
are lined up with salt light teeth it
also has three pairs of eyes that gives
it no blind spot at all it has massive
wings that enable it to fly almost as
fast as the Night Fury vegar is around
100 to 150 feet shorter and also less
bulky than the Red Death second here in
this list of dragons bigger than the
yellow bees of Hot D is none other than
smoke who is 427 feet or 130 meters long
and having a wingspan of over 360 feet
or 110 meters wide the villain of The
Hobbit smart was the last great Dragon
of Middle Earth although he was little
compared to his ancestors he was still a
really Dreadful and responsible for the
death and Exile of the dwarves from
airball Smart would be more than one and
a half times as long as vegar and
therefore even if he was Slimmer than
the other one he would still have a good
size advantage over vegar adult
bewildebees are incredibly massive
four-legged dragons with a pair of
gigantic tusks protruding from the size
of their heads they are Ocean Titans
from the world of a How to Train Your
Dragon they do look a bit silly though
having a flat face and two hypnotizing
eyes with a large flaring crown of
spikes and thrills are found out from
the back of their heads and they also
have wings but they are not used for
flying rather they are like appendages
that are adapted for swimming these
massive bees are 520 feet long or twice
the length of Vega and many times
bulkier and heavier
the next one is the buraki who is the
serpentine dragon that appeared in the
Korean fantasy foam d-walls his adopt
imogi who decides to become the new
Celestial Dragon so he can destroy both
Heaven and Earth and rebuild them in its
own image the buraki possesses virtually
unbreakable skin massive strength
amazing speed but cannot fly and
slithers around like a snake without
effort he can level buildings trees and
traffic to go where he wants to go as
well as borrow under the Earth he can
also create dark clouds this baraki is
650 feet or 200 meters long so two and a
half times longer than vegar
so the next one seen in God's licking of
the monsters as a rival apex predator to
Godzilla himself Master zero are also
known as Ghidorah was discovered
dominant inside the Antarctic glaciers
and was theorized to have been trapped
there for thousands of years he is a
three-headed dragon with a golden body
two massive wings and two long bob tails
at 521 feet tall his height alone is
already twice that of Vega's length and
when we take it to consideration his
actual length from the snout to the tip
of the tail Master zero would be around
900 to 1000 feet or between 300 to 330
meters long or four times longer than
vegar
this next dragon kinda looks like
Ghidorah and is a Japanese movie monster
or a kaju he is seen in the movie The
Three Treasures here Orochi his name
looks like a giant snake with eight
heads with eight small tails and a
massive body in another movie Orochi the
eight-headed dragon he now spots a more
draconic appearance with a bulky body
and stubby legs he is red with multiple
yellow horns on his head and small
spikes sticking out from the tail Orochi
differs from ghidoro as he has no wings
and instead of three he has eight heads
and also eight tails he is also similar
to Monster Zero in length an overall
size so so around 4 times bigger than
vegar there are other dragons like white
Ghidorah that can be included here but
he is also just another version
incarnation of Ghidorah so the seventh
Dragon bigger than Vega in this list
would be the world gobbler of the
animated French German film Dragon
Hunters aside from the wings the world
goblet is a dragon that greatly
resembles a full Tyrannosaurus skeleton
the spikes on the back however resemble
the back plates of another dinosaur the
stegosaurus this monstrous skeletal
Titan was over one thousand feet long
and therefore many times bigger than
Vega the yellow bees of aega on the
Conqueror
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos here on this channel till the
next one take care fam